[Music]
on this Monday night Canada's first
death from Kovac 19 we are deeply
saddened health officials reinforce an
important message we need to protect
each other and Canadians get ready to
disembark this contaminated cruise ship
breaking news on Italy's unprecedented
lockdown and the downward spiral for the
markets and oil prices Global News
investigates rising violence on Via Rail
trains he came at me with an axe the
push to better protect passengers and
stepping out one last time Harry and
Megan swonsong at senior Royals
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with fast-moving developments
about the corona virus including the
first reported death in Canada an
elderly man in British Columbia a
resident in a care home has died of
kovat 19 a reminder that it is the
elderly who are most at risk
tonight public health officers have a
message for Canadians now is the time
for all of us to self distance from each
other to reduce the chance of spreading
the virus it is time to start greeting
each other with elbow bumps or waves
instead of handshakes this is not an
overreaction but a very practical way of
limiting the spread of germs in Canada
there are now 77 cases that includes 34
in Ontario 32 NBC 7 in Alberta 4 in
Quebec and today the first death I want
to reassure Canadians that we have our
top medical experts our top scientists
on this issue we are coordinating with
authorities working together Canadians
are now being advised to avoid all
cruise ship travel the other big shop
today was a crash on stock markets and a
plummet in oil prices we're going to
explain all of that tonight we begin in
British Columbia with what we know about
the outbreak at that nursing home Robyn
Gill has our top story tonight this
long-term care facility in a Vancouver
suburb is home to seniors many who have
underlying medical concerns then the new
coronavirus somehow crept in and took
the life of one man this is obviously a
very sad day for all of us but
especially of course for the family and
loved ones of the man who passed away
another resident has tested positive a
health care worker got sick from working
here and there are more potential cases
of kovat 19 in the care home all of the
health care workers are being questioned
about where else they've been because as
part of the job they work at other
facilities and even hospitals it's a
challenge with our system health care
workers and we know that whether it's
care workers or nurses or even
physicians we work in many different
health authorities many different
facilities sometimes that is part of the
ongoing investigation
this omits persons for seniors says
there are already hundreds of outbreaks
of flu and pneumonia at care homes
across the country now at in Kovan 19
you've got people who are already
vulnerable
living in an environment where the
transmission of the virus is going to be
more difficult to control because
they're living in a communal environment
and they're touching things that a lot
of other people are touching just take a
look at what happened at a nursing home
in a Seattle suburb 13 residents and a
visitor died from the virus 70 staff
members are sick with symptoms
resembling the new corona virus it's an
occupational health and safety issue but
it's also a public health issue
Canada's Federation of nurses says
protocols for staff need to be reviewed
given this health crisis you need to
look at the uniforms look at cleaning
your shoes etc when you leave the
facilities at most care homes in
visits are being limited tests are being
done and extra staff are being brought
in there are no signs of Cova 19 at
other care homes in this country yet it
is very much a concern of ours this
disease is new it's evolving and it's
constantly on the move and that
uncertainty makes it even scarier for
the elderly
Robin Gill Global News North Vancouver
here's the big picture with kovat 19
right now there are more than a hundred
and thirteen thousand cases in the world
in more than 110 countries and there are
more than thirty nine hundred deaths it
has a foothold in so many countries now
and the risk of further spread keeps
rising because of that Canada's top
doctor has new advice for Canadians add
void all travel on cruise ships cruise
ships have passengers from around the
world who may be arriving for areas with
known or unknown spread of the novel
coronavirus bad advice is too late for a
thousands of passengers including 237
Canadians on board the Grand Princess
it's now docked at the Port of Oakland
California 21 people on board have
tested positive and tonight passengers
are disembarking you can see people
lined up at different tents including
the Canadian one everyone is a step
closer to getting to a hospital now or
to quarantine Canadians who are symptom
free will be put on a government
chartered flight to CFB Trenton in
Ontario abigail Beeman reports on how
they found out and what happens now an
announcement from the Grand Princess in
the middle of a global news interview
Ron Roman otto and Karen spoon Goldman
are two of the 237 Canadians on board
waiting to get home to Montreal Robert
Grubb of BC is more concerned about
medication than contracting coronavirus
and I'm still waiting for my medications
to arrive on board from princess at the
request of the United States Canada is
sending a plane to Oakland to pick up
Canadian
cruise passengers if they exhibit
symptoms of covin 19 they will not be
permitted to board they will be cared
for by the US healthcare system we have
agreed that that the cruise line will be
will be assuming the costs of the plane
to repatriate Canadians at this point
Canada is not issuing a travel advisory
to the United States where the number of
cases and deaths keep climbing we are
prepared and with this step today this
is the difference between being reactive
in planning ahead that's the mayor of
Detroit announcing the city will turn
the taps back on for people cut off from
water for not paying the bill we are
introducing New York State clean hand
sanitizer while New York distributes its
own hand sanitizer and the head of its
Port Authority contracted the virus this
is a superior product to products now on
the market different steps in different
states while the Trump administration is
criticized for a slow rollout of tests
deception and denial are not a strategy
what we've seen at the federal level is
too much low balling and bungling ads
for the president he didn't hold back
from shaking hands at a fundraiser stop
in Florida here in Washington one of the
first two people to contract the virus
is the rector of this church health
officials are asking anyone who came
into contact with him to self isolate
for 14 days and since he shook hands
with parishioners and provided Communion
that's likely to be hundreds of people
Abigail Beeman Global News Washington
it's been anything but smooth sailing on
the stock market today fears of the
spread of kovat 19 plus a crash in oil
prices pushed rattled investors to sell
so fast today trading was temporarily
halted at one point crude oil prices
nosedive the biggest single-day dropped
since 1991 shares in oil companies fell
with them Brent crude the international
benchmark fell nearly 30 percent at one
point dipping to $32 US a barrel the
plummet was so steep trading circuit
breakers were tripped this morning to
pause the system and calm the panic the
Dow Jones ended the day more than 2,000
points down closing below 24,000 points
the TSX in Toronto took
10% closing more than 1,600 points down
david akin is keeping track of all of
this for us on the impact on Canada
David right well we start the day with
the idea that worldwide travel has dried
up because of Kovan 19:00 and with
no-one using those planes trains and
cruise ships the demand for fuel has
plummeted that in turn has put downward
pressure on oil prices now Saudi Arabia
wanted to keep oil prices up by cutting
back on production but Russia would not
go along and so Saudi Arabia decided
Sunday to slash its oil prices betting
that Saudi Arabia could stand the pain
of lower oil prices longer than Russia
could but now every oil producing
country including Canada has had to cut
prices which means less revenue for
sectors connected to the energy industry
less revenue equals less profit and
there's your stock market sell-off this
is a global bun fight that has Canada
just in the crosshairs between Saudi
Arabia and Russia and so it's not
something where we have a lot of ability
to control it so David is there anything
the federal government could do to
mitigate the impact on Canada's economy
what did the finance minister say today
well Bill Morneau just finished talking
to us and he first of all wanted to
offer some reassurance he said Canada's
fiscal position very healthy relatively
low debt second he wanted to assure
Canadians that our banking system is
fine he says both of those things are
strengths that will help the government
help Canadians of course we're also
making sure that we tell people that we
have their backs that we are thinking
about impacts on individuals employees
that we are focused on how we can
support businesses to the extent
businesses needs as we be supported but
any specific measures are days away
we're working on on some responses right
now so I think what you'll see from us
is a continued approach whereas we have
measures that we think they're
appropriate to roll out based on the
facts we will do so and you'll see some
things this week the drop in oil prices
David is the last thing all producers in
this country need Alberta premier Jason
Kenney sounds like he might be moving
into crisis mode what's he planning yeah
very close to a very serious very sober
premier this afternoon
Jenny said this oil price shock
represents what he called a profound
challenge for Alberta and for Canada
hundreds of thousands of Canadians
depend on the energy sector directly for
their livelihoods and all 36 million
Canadians benefited from benefit from it
at least indirectly now Kenny and all
other premiers are going to be in Ottawa
later this week to meet with Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau and by then we
expect to learn when will Bill Morneau
table this year's budget and the
Premier's like Kenny will certainly be
looking to this week's meetings to get a
sense of just exactly how Ottawa plans
to help Donna all right David akin in
Ottawa thanks in Italy the lockdown in
the North has now been extended to the
entire country of 60 million people
travel is restricted public events
including weddings and funerals have
been halted and popular tourist
destinations are deserted the death toll
in Italy from kovat 19:00 jumped by 97
to 463 today the Prime Minister calls
the outbreak in Italy its darkest hour
there are more than nine thousand cases
making Italy the second-largest
epicentre outside China and the worst in
Europe countries around the world are
beginning to further restrict the
movement of people to slow the spread in
the Republic of Ireland Saint Patrick's
Day parades have all been canceled the
parade in Dublin which usually attracts
half a million people is a massive boost
for tourism not this year
Ireland has 21 Kovach 19 cases and the
Health Minister expects a rapid
escalation in the days ahead but we know
you have lots of questions about this
virus and we want to help answer them
you can send an email to your questions
at global news dot CA our Jeff Semple
will consult experts to try to find the
answers you'll also find extensive
information on our website we have a
special page dedicated entirely to the
new corona virus that's a global news CA
/ corona virus the trial of four men
accused in the shooting down of a
Malaysian Airlines passenger plane is
now underway in the Netherlands nearly
300 people died when that aircraft was
hit by a surface-to-air missile over
eastern Ukraine in 2014 the four accused
didn't pull the trigger on the missile
system but they are believed to have put
it in the hands of the people who did
Mike Armstrong explains in a trial set
to stretch over several months one of
the first steps on this day one was to
enter the names of the victims into the
record
Peter dose being op dual okay it would
take this Dutch prosecutor 18 minutes to
read all 298 hearing those names for
family members in court was bittersweet
it's so important to find a true fan
it's a sad day but exciting Dutch
authorities have charged three Russians
and one Ukrainian for their roles in the
shooting down of the aircraft at the
time each was in a senior position in
the rebel militias that controlled
eastern Ukraine they're being tried for
murder in absentia they're all believed
to be in Russia only one has a legal
team participating Stella Thompkins
Oleg Paula Tom's lawyer says her client
had nothing to do with what happened but
a Dutch led joint investigative team
concluded the missile system had been
moved from Russia and fired by
pro-russian rebels the reports 13
witnesses will testify in the trial but
their identities will be kept secret
Canadian Michael bossa q was an observer
on the ground in the aftermath of mh17
he's in the Netherlands for the trial
bas accuses witnesses have been
threatened and that in this case those
threats should be taken seriously when
witnesses are threatened it could be as
bad as a bullet to the head so very very
difficult circumstances well the trial
is underway the investigative team
continues its work and has dozens of
other names of people involved the trial
has started but new suspects could be
added down the road Mike Armstrong
Global News coming up Ottawa's push to
outlaw conversion therapy
the federal government has introduced
legislation that would amend the
Criminal Code and ban conversion therapy
the discredited practice seeks to change
a person's sexual orientation or gender
identity it's been resoundingly rejected
both medically and scientifically and
denounced as harmful a number of cities
and provinces have already imposed bans
on it Heather Eurex West explains why
the federal government is taking this
next step
Jonathan Brower was 20 the first time he
took part in conversion therapy deeply
religious he felt he had no choice but
to try and do whatever he could to not
be gay it's not a choice when your faith
family and community give you no option
but heterosexuality so at that point you
either leave your faith and stand to
lose everyone you love who are you try
to fit the picture of what they want not
only was the therapy unsuccessful it
left brower's feeling hopeless and
suicidal conversion therapy has been
discredited
and denounced by professional and Health
Association's in Canada and in the
United States and around the world it
has no basis in science or health care
practices rather its devastating effects
have been felt time and time again the
Liberal government's proposed bill would
change Canada's Criminal Code providing
conversion therapy to anyone under age
18 would be a crime and it would also be
illegal to advertise or benefit from the
practice financially the survivors like
advocate Erica Muse it says the bill
doesn't go far enough and leaves people
vulnerable I can't say that this is what
I need and what Canadians need to make
sure no one else is hurt like me I can't
say that this is a ban that would make
me safe the Justice Minister says the
bill worked to balance progressive
policy with constitutional
considerations Brower it's still an
important step these organizations and
systems believe have really pathologized
something beautiful and called it simple
so this is a pivotal Canadian moment I
believe to right that wrong heather
Yorick's West Global News Calgary ahead
what hidden safety risks are travelers
facing on via rail
you
you are watching global national we're
examining rail travel in this country
tonight some people rely on via rail
passenger service in Canada but not
every ride is completely safe there's
been a rise in violent attacks and
security onboard is scarce though via is
working on increasing it tonight Megan
Robinson investigates the scope of the
problem and the risks to passengers and
crew for 35 years fabian be so
cheerfully served and entertained for
Eurail passengers he often worked on the
canadian the world-famous route between
Vancouver and Toronto it can be a
comfortable ride despite frequent delays
five-star hotel on wheels
but be saw who retired earlier this year
saw another side of train travel we saw
says the two men fighting in this video
were later arrested by RCMP we know when
we get the people coming in to us
because they are acting a certain way
and when this is taking place you know
if you gotta have a good trip or a bad
trip you know if you're gonna call the
cops at one point or not call the cops
in 2011 besause teenage daughter was on
board at 2:00 a.m. the saw says she was
startled awake by a man wildly swinging
an axe I grabbed him by the troll and I
squeezed in so much and he fell from the
ground that was a moment of my life
what I was fighting because I didn't
know if that guy was gonna come up
enough attacks like these used to be
isolated according to former and current
employees we spoke to but internal via
rail statistics show an increase of
violence or unruly behavior on board
after October 2018 that also happens to
be when Greyhound canceled bus routes in
Western Canada documents obtained by
Global News show at least 20 security
incidents on Western Canadian train
routes from January 2017 to November
2018 but after the Greyhound
cancellations
there was a spike in just over a year
there were at least 46 security
incidents more than double the previous
two years combined
there has been morning that have not
even been investigated yet and now
that's becoming a problem because I
don't know if we're trying to hang those
because there is a problem some of that
recent violence on board the Canadian
includes a knife attack and a passenger
tasering an attendant what employees are
now facing between Vancouver and Toronto
may be symptoms of larger national
issues related to homelessness mental
illness and drug abuse
we take social issue with us we put it
on board we're going to carry them
somewhere and somewhere else in the
country they're not a drop-in they're
not a shelter they're not a mental
health agency so seamless with on planes
you know you expect people to provide
first aid or be kind help people but
they have a much different job and role
Via Rail declined an on-camera interview
but said in a statement Via Rail Canada
Police has 14 appointed constables it
also says it works with community
partners to address education prevention
and crisis intervention strategies for
those with mental illness or substance
dependency Transport Canada says it's
proposing new regulations requiring
passenger rail companies to improve
their own security but this all says he
wants to see improved security measures
immediately don't want to wait for
someone to get hurt or that killed even
died you know of a situation before we
act
Megan Robinson Global News Toronto
tomorrow we look at Via Rail how
reliable it is and isn't and just how
costly the delays can be next Harry and
Megan take their last steps in the royal
spotlight
[Music]
you
call it their swan song the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex have carried out their
final public engagement as working
members of the royal family Harry and
Megan attended the Commonwealth service
at Westminster Abbey today they were
ushered to their seats ahead of the
Queen's entrance as was Harry's brother
William and his wife Kate a couple's
once known as the Fab Four were seated
close to each other it's not clear when
they'll all be together again queen
elizabeth ii entered the abbey with the
usual pomp and ceremony the service
marks the end of a two-month family
drama that became public when harry and
megan posted on instagram they planned
to chart a new course for themselves and
give up royal life
harry will remain 6th in line to the
throne but at the end of the month
they'll stop using their royal titles
they'll also give up most public funding
and intend to earn their own living and
for now they're expected to return to
their new life here in canada and that
is global national for this Monday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
really your night sky this is the first
super moon of 2020 at 100% illumination
it is 2000 times brighter than the next
brightest object Venus so keep an eye
out for it and thanks for watching bye
bye
you